when did you start to get like a new
perspective kind of march
23rd and 95 i walked into that treatment
center and i remember
thinking to myself like i could picture
that that stainless steel
door like industrial door and thinking
to myself the fun's over
yeah but i was like i'd rather be boring
and sober than miserable and drunk
or an alcoholic life and
11 days later i stayed in that treatment
center 17 days at
day 11 i started laughing again
and uh
my gut hurt from laughing that day wow
and i was like i forgot about that you
noticed it i forgot about that feeling
that powerful
and i was like i don't know what's
happening but i'm digging my claws into
it
and i've been laughing ever since damn
even on the tragic days there's been
some kind of laughter even if it's been
internal
like amusement in my own head like it's
you know like we make fun of her poke
fun of ourselves
oh yeah i don't have to sit and laugh
out loud to be
you know put things in perspective but
you know even on days
where my mom died three years or three
and a half years ago it was like a hard
day for me and
and and and really it was like the
harder year after was harder for me than
that
week that you know that she had died and
stuff she always have stuff to do that
week
yeah i kick into like you know i got to
get things done there's responsibilities
i gotta you know make sure things are
right
and then once you sit you know that
passes and then you sink in and then
you're not buying that ticket
to go see mom in november like to see
her for christmas
because you're like mom ain't there i'm
gone that's when you're like
[__] that's heavy
um so you so you went in there you
started to get better
yeah yeah like yeah day 11 started
laughing again and then
yeah those little things man you notice
i i remember
having uh a thought that made me laugh i
remember just driving one time
and um and i've struggled in and out
over my five years in recovery but i've
never given up on
on the program or or trying to uh
you know i haven't given up on that path
yet in my life um
and i'm trying it new now you know
trying it again um
but i remember yeah a time when i
just was driving down the road and i
laughed just by myself and i was like
[__] i haven't done that in months
just the little things that were like um
that you just came or just like i
remember i woke up in the middle of the
night one night and i didn't have a
thought in my head
and it was like jesus christ this is so
nice
the noise is not there yeah just like
especially for someone like you
yeah well it's like somebody started
like somebody left something plugged in
that's rattling like
40 years ago and it's rattling all the
and i can't
find it put a twist tie around that
thing yeah
something i'm just sitting on your front
porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been